This is a fascinating segment that goes to the
limits of political loyalty, because there are
some Trump supporters whose undying support for
Trump has no limit. But for some Trump supporters,
their support of Trump does have a limit. And
that limit is called the coronavirus vaccine.
You're going to be probably horrified by these
clips after a year of Donald Trump telling his
own supporters that the pandemic isn't serious,
calling it the China virus, that you don't need a
vaccine. Some of those Trump supporters now don't
want the vaccine. They see the vaccine as liberal
nonsense, especially as they see Joe Biden as the
one who is so quickly accelerating vaccination.
Nearly three million doses the last two days.
We'll talk about that tomorrow, but that's very
good news. So CNN sends their reporter, Gary
Tuchman, to a diner in Boise City, Oklahoma.
And it is compelling video. This county was a 92
percent Trump County back in November. But right
now we have some conflicting numbers. We know that
most Republican voters still like Trump, but about
half of Republicans don't want the vaccine. As of
last week, Trump now recommends to his followers
that they get the vaccine. So we have a
statistical conflict. They mostly like Trump who's
saying get the vaccine, but half of them don't
want the vaccine. How does this conflict manifest?
Gary Tuchman asks the diners questions
about the vaccine. It got awkward and very
ignorant. Let's take a look at the first clip.
It's breakfast time in Boise City, Oklahoma.
And I have this question. Does anybody
in this restaurant think it's a good
idea to take the vaccine? You know, raise
your hand if you think it's a good idea.
Anyone here is a good idea to take the vaccine.
Raise your hand if you think it's a good idea.
Not one person here thinks it's a good idea.
Complete quiet, so
that's already not so good.
And then Gary Tuchman speaks to some specific
people and here I would get the kids out of the
room for this. This is ugly, ugly stuff that
we're about to see. Take a look. What do you
think about the vaccine? Are you going to
take the vaccine? No, sir. Tell me why.
I don't trust the government and I don't trust.
Chad and Mr. Hughes are husband and wife. Neither
of them plan to get the vaccine. Just
go on to the. Why don't you want if you
don't mind me asking, because when I take
the flu shot, I usually get the flu. So
there's no reason to take that. Are you saying you
think you'll get covered by taking the vaccine?
Are you? Why are you thinking that? The
research doesn't show that at all. Shows
that it keeps us safe. That's just my choice.
So that first guy is bad enough who says I don't
trust the government or Biden? Because
remember, the vaccine was developed
not because of Trump, but it was
developed during Trump's administration.
Trump is taking credit for it. Trump's people
initially oversaw the initial distribution, which
was completely abortive, but still, like the first
guy doesn't care. Now, Joe Biden is president.
Now is when that guy could get a vaccine and
he doesn't trust the government or Joe Biden.
But the second guy, the flu shot usually gives me
the flu. Can't happen. It's impossible. Doesn't
happen. So I will assume that the covid vaccine
will give me covid. That's not necessarily a Trump
Biden thing. That's total vaccine ignorance
that appears to go beyond politics, although
it seems to still exist more on the right than
on the left. Let's look at another one of these
absolutely horrifying clips.
These women are sisters
and they, too, are doubter's. You know,
they just started rolling them out.
Well, yeah, but I mean, this has
been a worldwide effort by great
time that the flu can be cured. There's still
hundreds of thousands of people back from the flu.
Well, yes, but not nearly as much as cold. And
this is a horrible pandemic. And this is like
the amazing vaccine. These vaccines have
come out. They're saving lives, I believe.
No, I would just agree to
disagree on this subject.
I guess
I just I'm just not
going to take it. She said they
claim the flu can be cured,
but people still die of the flu despite having
a vaccine. So this is like it's the brain. Is
it is it Pudi? Is it? I don't know what to call
it. No one claims the flu vaccine cures flu. The
idea is the flu vaccine prevents flu in some and
in others it makes it less severe. But the flu
vaccines are not nearly as effective as these
coronavirus vaccines are. And if you wonder how
does someone get tricked by Trump into believing
he's going to build a wall and that Mexico will
pay for it, that will fix trade, that he'll put in
a beautiful health care plan. These are the same
people that believe the flu shot will give you
the flu, right? These are the people we're talking
about that fell for that stuff and were tricked
into voting for Donald Trump. Here's another clip.
What if President Trump came out and was a very
robust and said, take the vaccine, I took it even
though unintelligible developers could have done
secretly, but I think you should take it. He said
it a little bit, but he hasn't been robust about
it. He was robust and said, take it. Would you
know how some liberal New Yorker,
why would we listen to him either?
Did you vote for him? Who was the best option?
What's funny about that Trump voter who says
Trump's a liberal New Yorker? Why would I listen
to him anyway? That antipathy that came out there,
that cultural clash, the diners in Oklahoma are
like this got Trump in the end, is just like a
rich liberal New Yorker that exists on Trump's
behalf as well. And what I mean by that is
the vast majority of Trump supporters, as
I've said so many times, are the types of
people that Donald Trump spent his life trying
to stay away from. So it's fascinating stuff,
but it is very disturbing to see these clips and
some of what these folks talk about. You know,
it's like what's more dangerous, getting covid of
the vaccine. The answer is obvious. Getting covid
is far more dangerous than any side effects you
would have from the vaccine. Another question is,
what's more dangerous, getting the virus or being
that ignorant, like what other risks to their
lives exist or are created because of the degree
of ignorance that they exhibit during interviews
like this? It is wacky, wacky stuff. And, you
know, I told the story last week of I spent time
in rural northern Indiana. And while I don't agree
with the political views of the people, they're
seeing it and seeing how basically you grow up in
a church and on a gun range, that's what there is
in northern Indiana, being told that guns and
abortion are the two most important things.
Of course, you're not voting for Democrats
because you're for 18 years by the time you
can vote and longer by the time you
know you're older, that's all that
you that's all that's there and that's all
that. That is your experience. Of course,
you're not going to vote for Joe Biden based on
what is publicly said. We have to understand these
folks because as ignorant as they are, if they
don't get vaccinated, it's bad for all of us.
And unfortunately, the sort of ignorance is bliss
type of thing. It may work for them, but it's
still dangerous for many others. So interesting.
Interesting segment there. Gary Tuchman with CNN.